[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bof
waouh pas trop d'accord mon gros
nounours tu leur montre le livre et moi
je leur raconte la suite des aventures
du petit cornichons bon le schmoll oraux
au sens
bonsoir m'échapper ne poussez pas comme
store voilà tu est posée et maintenant
tu nous montres la suite de l'histoire
de cornichons et du chant cheval d'un
avoue patron vous pouvez raconter au
fond potro cornichons est revenu sur la
grande plage la plage we see perdu oui
mes dadas n'est pas là son papa et sa
maman non plus ils sont tous partis à sa
recherche
pas de chance et il y a seulement un
vieux vitrier qui pousse une charrette
plein de morceaux de verre ce bien lourd
lui dit le vieux vitrier alors notre
petite amie l'aide à pousser sa
charrette taille la banque et il arrive
dans une grande ville où il y a des
grandes maisons vue truc
cris le vieux vitrier tous nous
l'étrier vitry cris cornichons je
voudrais une vitre ronde pour mettre
dans mes lunettes
j'ai un verre de cassez demande une dame
maigre très grande qui porte sur la tête
un chignon maigre et pointue elle est
bonne et la dame rose que le manche 6 go
faisons pro de coûteuses le cornichon
lui coupent un beau vert bien carré
qu'il met à la place de celui qui manque
la dame a de drôles de lunettes sur le
nez avec un verre rond est inverse car
et c'est bien faire de toute façon elle
est moche synchro le petit et tous les
enfants qui passent dans la rue vie en
la montrant du doigt alors la dame se
regardent dans une glace et quand elle
se voit elle se met très fort en colère
ce cornichons il l'est vraiment
mais le vieux vitrier ne se fâche pas il
sait que le petit corniche on est un peu
dans la lune et pour le remercier de
l'aider à pousser sa charrette
il lui donne une merveilleuse bouteilles
en verre de venise ou trust you dit non
nous quand est-ce qu'on le reverra gaga
et les parents de cornichons surtout toi
bien
tous
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
elle vous a plu oui elle est très jolie
cette histoire merci des marchands de
sable voulons le pitch ou tout bon non
[Musique]
beaune ou vins de nichane n'ose pas nui
nicolas bonita prenait lé tort bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit petites tapes renel bonne
nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit tous les
enfants allaient sagement vous coucher
et faites de beaux rêves fait de pauvres
me voilà patron alors en route mon cher
nounours ben des nuits à demain adobe
est bonne
[Musique]